megyn kelly the filthy
well frankly what you're talking about
the media okay you're talking about a
very shallow talent pool you're talking
about a pool that's so shallow I could
put my I could put my toddler in it okay
you've got if whatever it includes megyn
kelly if your talent pool for legitimate
journalists okay that frankly I love
women
I have always respected women okay I've
made several of them they call me the
woman making machine
but megyn kelly is such a [ __ ] she
sleeps with everybody at foxnews she
sleeps with everybody at CNN it's
well-known for a long time she's going
to come up and ask me at quarter mia by
sexist she doesn't ask any of the other
candidates that they're sexist that who
asks me okay truthfully was horrible if
I'm sexist I'm not sexist I just don't I
just don't like being asked question is
by horse and bacon Kelly's a [ __ ] but
if I if I could reach out to the non
[ __ ] community okay the community of
all the women out there who frankly
nobody knows or cherishes women better
than Donald Trump if I could reach out
to the non [ __ ] community they would
take my calls they would take my calls
we talked about megyn kelly the [ __ ]
that frankly they take my calls
look here to hear me talk about China
you